bonjour si on n'est pas du nord ont ce
n'est pas ce que c'est qu'une beast ou
alors pire on on va leur dire un par un
ceux qui n'ont pas la chance du nord ce
que c'est qu'une veste ou alors c'est du
café à rosette genièvre vous êtes génial
le genièvre qu'on peut mettre dans le
café ou alors qu'on met dans sa tasse
cantat est vite quand la tasse est
encore tiède
oui donc c'est ça la bistade l'histoire
et bistoule avec le genièvre de
préférence parce que c'est la gnôle du
nord on nous dit en neuvième et je sais
que dans le nord oui c'est pas toujours
chaud soyons honnêtes le matin en
particulier aux trois quarts les
ouvriers partir au travail à vélo un
monde prend doucement vélo il faisait
froid et quand on est arrivé pour se
réchauffer on a l'habitude la vistule du
genièvre et je garde le souvenir dans
les cafés même moi puisque j'étais gamin
les ouvriers qui n'est pas dans le 10ème
et leur café on comptait pas le café
vivent autant de cafés qui voulait on
comptait première donc c'était jeudi
matin une tradition et pas un seul
johnny avant et pendant qu'on est
plusieurs bons sa vie qu'est ce que
c'est que le genièvre mal génial c'est
une autre vie de céréales d'orge et de
blé qui est parfumé bien sûr avec des
baies de genièvre c'est une autre vie
parait-il qui a été inventé par les
hollandais nous vient de hollande
mon cher piron est donc cette cette
eau-de-vie donc été apportée en france à
la fin du xviiie siècle et en 1804 dans
le département du nord il y avait 72
distillerie de genièvre
si vous dire que mon but mais bon
aujourd'hui il a plus que trois il reste
la distillerie de houle dans le pas de
calais et puis deux autres distillerie
dans les environs de lille la
distillerie de wambrechies qu est ce qu
a connues ont dit vendredi sur l'anjou
du laus parce que notre distillerie
celles de l'osce exactement tout à côté
de lille
alors on est allé voir comment fabriquer
ce jeune est vrai la distillerie de l'os
et bien c'est pas très compliqué ça
commence par la cuisson de la farine de
blé et d'orge de façon à transformer
l'amidon des céréales en sucres et ce
mou de sucre est qu'on obtient eh bien
il est mise en fermentation pendant 48
heures dans des grandes cuves comme vous
voyez et à l'issue de la fermentation et
bien on procède à une première
distillation du moins sur des colonnes à
plateau les vapeurs d'alcool ils sont
réfrigérés et ça donne
igm qui sont filtrés et distiller une
seconde fois dans des alambics en cuivre
cette fois en présence de baies de
genièvre qui vont donner le parfum
l'eau-de-vie ainsi obtenu est mise
ensuite à à vieillir dans des fûts en
bois de chêne plus ou moins longtemps
selon la qualité qu'on veut donner au
genièvre et c'est toute vie ensuite bien
sûr et est mise en bouteille
[Musique]
voilà ça se boit au comptoir le genièvre
et puis c'est aussi une autre vie qui
très utilisée en cuisine dans le nord
comme on va le voir tout de suite bien
entendu avec notre ami pierrot qui nous
a qui va nous concocter aujourd'hui
alors les les rognons de veau au génial
fogiel volatile a déjà pesé dans un
petit rôle on va couper mais rod you mom
et rognons de veau
alors regardez pierre on va les faire un
petit morceau y aller on peut faire des
rognons de veau entier ouais arrive en
cuisine souvent on voulait souvenu
entier ont toutes un jour là mais là je
le coupe en petit en petits quartiers et
là je vous ai pris à rognan comme on
trouve encore des petites boucheries
campagne c'est à dire où leurs oignons
dans la grèce et la bêtise abattoirs
yankel rognons de la grèce est là si
vous l'avez entouré dans la grèce comme
ça au frigo regardez en place voilà où
ça ne bouge pas pendant cinq six jours
il n'y a pas de problème donc voilà le
rognon comme envoyée dans la graisse
regarder et ses graisses et la rigueur
dans leur dans les cuisines
traditionnelles on faisait fondre on
s'en servait des soins vous voyez donc
voilà je n'ai laissé à rognan un peu de
graisse pour vous voyez ya pas tout à
fait la même table parce qu'évidemment
il était ridley voilà un lot et voilà
leur union qui dans la grèce en langue
et encore plus frais donc nous avons
deux oignons différent on peut mélanger
lier en cuisant ça sera pas voilà j'ai
voulu vous voyez ce que c'était que les
différents rayons alors vous faites les
rognons vent comme une personne
bon normalement là où ici on va faire
pour 4 personnes c'est à dire il faut
compter à peu près 120 à 150 g de
réunion par personne selon l'appétit
qu'on a évidemment non ça se baser sur
150 g donc son contenu 5 600 g ça fait à
peu près de rognons
de rognons de veau par personne de
rognons de veau pour 4 personnes
d'accord alain gretz dian à deux
ingrédients lauzun gré des envies d'un
aréna sinon ça arrive que des amis le
bob lubbers bon un petit peu de beurre
ben vous voyez vous croiserez comme moi
20 à 30 g de beurre en vastes
proportions
quand les rognons seront revenues bien
revenue dans le vert nous mettons un peu
déçu notent un petit peu des chaleurs
nous mettrons un peu de champignons
clopinante paris quelques pays où on
prend les points de chute et met tout de
suite les mettront peut-être après
quelques baies de genièvre et si vous
voulez on en mettra de la paris à soupe
de farine pour lier un petit peu nos
métros non champignons nous plongerons
jeune hyène un soupçon de bas blancs
apple crème fraîche et dauphine rock
petites passes et de moutarde et vous
verrez les rognons ça va très très vite
à première vue alors la cuisson jusqu'à
cuisson complète comme d'habitude mais
ce qui va falloir sa détention les aime
rosé ou bien via lapointe a justement où
les aimez vous tiers rien à voir bien
bon et ben voilà donc plus on les coupe
en petits morceaux plus on va gagner du
temps pour la cuisson
bon en ce qu'il faut faire c'est
regarder voyez je prends le nerf du
milieu ont du cran et lunaire je sais
pas prendre ce nerf et ce gras du milieu
et si on est un petit peu bon évidemment
ça fondera c'est un problème des faux
papiers
je vais mettre ma peau allait chauffer
et nous allons mettre le beurre qui
veulent avoir une petite couleur
toujours pareil il faut au narbr quelle
couleur pas noisette mais un beurre bien
chaud voyez a pas tellement de déchets
c'est très brouillon et ils sont très
frais ce sens voilà le rester pour chat
ou alors les baies de genièvre cdb que
j'avais des baies de genièvre frêche je
les ai eus à wambrechies dans la
distillerie juin voyage grâce à vos
émissions et donc j'ai fait tremper dans
le genièvre et donc s'ils voulaient
elles seront elles sont très moelleuse
il faut le ça donnera un bon petit voile
offshore en baisse mais pourtant m 2
trouve pas que il faut en avoir quatre
ou cinq petites boules dans les recettes
découlant mais d'autres non voyez le
vert comme enseigne à chaud on va
pouvoir plonger leurs oignons il paraît
que c'est très bon de croquer les baies
de genièvre commencer vous dégoûter déjà
ah oui bah c'est bon le doute et il
paraît que c'est un vaccin contre le
rhume on m'a dit sabres en hiver se
prendre quelques petites bêtes geneviève
comme ça les croquer le matin et ben
n'empêche d'avoir des rubis moi j'essaye
donc je fais que leurs aînés rognon
saisir et comme il parle déjà de la
couleur alors des rognons de veau comme
ça vraiment quatre ou cinq minutes de
cuisson dans le beurre ça va suffire à
les semer rognon alors pierre la cuisson
des rognons comme là on peut appeler on
le voit à l'oeil disons instant été on
le voit à l'oeil les rognons commence
déjà cette rose est donc maintenant on
va attaquer la partie qu'on va les cuire
un peu plus voyez là pour des revenus
résultant de finir la sauce c'est comme
ça donc là on le voit j'ai souvent ils
sont renvoyés rails son rosé point il ya
des amateurs d'oignons top de rognons
pardon il ya les amateurs de rognons
quand ils disent saignant donc on sait
qu'on devra commencé à flamber à ce
moment là ah ouais comme vous aimez
assez cuit donc on a le temps voilà
alors toujours pareil je vais saler
poivrer
après qu'on a bien travaillé les rognons
pourquoi tu le sens vont même reste à
l'intérieur si on sale fois avant tout
les rognons mobile et blanches ou alors
un match un peu de sel encore encore way
va très bien l'alliance petite salle
hier un peu avant a dit alors ce que je
vais faire ça même si une petite bricole
qu'on peut faire je vais simplement vidé
un peu d'excédent de graisses et de jus
et c'est ce jus qui revient qui peut des
fois bon ça va enlever après ce premier
coup du rognon dépôt c'est l'épaule
renault a quand même si vous quand dans
le bassin champlevé ça alors je le
dégoûte c'est une bonne idée wade l'a
bon petit truc
voilà avec nos auditeurs des tétons bien
que vous leur donner des trucs comme ça
alors regardez bien
donc si vous voulez le jus l'excédent de
vue des rognons est parti on a vraiment
le trognon attaque et 6,6 quoi s'occuper
9 flambage est finie en euros n'ont
jamais un type et d'échalotes et là ça
va très vite vous lire tout y est alors
on va mettre sa part inna tout petit peu
on va faut remettre beaucoup c'est
simplement pour le lier comme cela se
passe pas très bien lié mais faut
remettre beaucoup vraiment un soupçon et
c'est à ce moment là c'est quand même
bien faire une police pas qu un petit
peu qu'on va demander à prendre votre
adresse de votre foyer
un tout petit peu simplement pour lier
oui c'est pas beaucoup
et voilà je vais rajouter mais p john f
deux pincées de passer mon jolliffe
alors là combien genièvre alors un à
deux verres bonjour je peux bien voilà
un soupçon de vin blanc pour arrêter la
cuisson
juliette semble a joué un petit groupe
simplement pour une histoire rebattue je
mets mes champignons à ses champions
paris ils ont ils sont déjà cuites le
circuit des champions de paris alors
soit vous les mettez sauter se voulait
au beurre ou cuit à l'ancienne peu un en
principe nous les moches un petit peu de
crème fraîche a comme d'habitude j'aime
bien ça comme tu respires oui je viens
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de joueurs
déploient dans la cuisine moderne il on
se sait fond de veau et non travail de
fond de veau c'est cette sauce qui est
sûr pour naulleau qui est toujours là
malins qui par une finalement tous les
plats mais hélas la can mais évidemment
la crème fraîche et voilà
et nous rognons pierre à bout de
champignons qui se barrent nous rognons
voilà c'est le moment d'aller certains
la csg on a fait fort de allons les
chauffer un petit peu et on va mettre
une toute petite
alors vraiment ça dépend pour relever un
petit peu ça c'est le petit truc mais
tout y passe et de moutain simplement
pour donner un petit peu de goût mais
pas beaucoup il faut qu'il ya toujours
ce petit goût piquant
ah c'est pas les oignons et la moutarde
nous met un petit bout discrètement pour
parra et damien - restaurateurs gila qui
m'a dit si tu cites et rognons c'est
comme ça et un petit peu à la fois bon
on se copient tous un petit peu puis en
apéritif ce qu'on peut prendre ces
briques evans apéritif à base de
genièvre d'andré qu'on appelle le ch
morales et charles morel voilà donc
avant les rognons peut savourer leur a
coupé persil frais au dernier moment
pour lui donner un peu de verdure et
voilà mes oignons sont très saccadé
vraiment très rapide à la bonne
franquette n'est pas tabou aujourd'hui
goûtez moi ça il ya bien là pas vous
voyez va bien merci
[Musique]